- I'm Greg Jennings, and
this is Build Your Squad.
♪♪♪ Rhythmic music ♪♪♪
I'm here right now with B/R Gridiron
to build my all-time squad.
Whoo-hoo-hoo!
OK, I am going to start
with my quarterback,
and this, for me, is rather easy,
and I'mma tell you why.
I'm goin' with Tom Brady.
He's the most clutch quarterback I've seen
in action, close-up, on television.
He has the most Super Bowls,
so if I'm looking for
somebody to win me a game,
I'm goin' with that guy.
That's my guy.
I don't care what you say.
[Clapping]
Next, running back.
Now, you're gonna be
a little disappointed,
possibly, maybe not.
I really don't care.
We got the great Walter Payton.
I love Walter Payton.
I would put him there,
but then we got Jim Brown and we got all—
But I grew up in Michigan.
Hear me.
I grew up in Michigan,
so I watched this guy my entire life.
Special.
Said, "You know what?
I'm so special, I'm done.
I don't even wanna play no more.
I'm too good for this league."
That's not what he said, but
that's kinda what I felt like,
because he was the only bright
spot on the Detroit Lions
and seemed to be the only
bright spot that ever existed
on the Detroit Lions.
So, Barry Sanders.
Doesn't matter what you think.
That's my pick.
I'm going to skip this row
for now and come back later.
I'm going to go to my defensive backs.
And it's, it's rather easy.
I mean, Prime.
I mean, do I have to explain why?
I mean, the ultimate
prime-time playmaker.
I mean, I got punt return covered.
I got, I got all secondary levels covered
because he's done it all.
I can isolate him one-on-one.
I can do whatever I need to do. We got it.
We good.
And we the fastest man on the field,
so I mean, need I say more?
I'm gonna go here to my
defensive end/linebacker.
This is tough.
This is really tough
because I played against this guy, Ray.
I played against this guy, Derrick Brooks.
I didn't play against Bruce Smith,
although I recognize the greatness.
I did not play against
the great Reggie White,
although I respect and
realize how great he was.
But Tecmo Bowl told me
that Lawrence Taylor was that dude then,
and I feel like if he played right now,
he would still be that dude.
Just special. I mean, he was
the only player on Tecmo Bowl
that could actually catch Bo Jackson.
Like, and you can't catch Bo Jackson!
Like, who—
what is that?
That's Lawrence Taylor, man.
He created and pathed the way
for guys like Ray Lewis.
That's why I'm—that's why I gotta put
Lawrence Taylor there.
And for receiver,
now,
I know the pick, naturally,
everyone would say, "Oh,
I'm goin' Jerry Rice."
My favorite player, probably all-time.
However...
"Who can make a play?
I can!" And he can.
I'm not pickin' him right now,
but that man right there,
he just was special.
Randy Moss, man. I mean, it's like—
and I know you're gonna say,
"Aw, man, he was only a deep threat,
and he couldn't go across the middle."
I don't care. I don't need
him to go across the middle.
Do what you do.
That's why he up here.
That's why his face is here, and—
I mean, mine should've been,
but I told 'em, "Don't put it up there,"
cuz I don't wanna—
that's biased. I didn't wanna be that.
And now I'mma lock my picks.
This is my squad.
I don't care what you think.
If you say, "Greg, naw, man,
whatchu—are you kidding me?"
I'mma say, "So, yeah. I
guess I am kidding you."
If you say, "Greg, that's amazing.
Now, I woulda had the same five,"
I would say, "I know. That's
why I put 'em up there."
But these are my five.
This who I'm goin' into any game with,
and I'm winnin'.
And we gonna get a buncha these.
A bunch of 'em.